i want to pull up this tweet here
from benny johnson
savage canadian conservative leader puts
final nail in trudeau's coffin in
parliament in front of the whole world
this is a truly epic 30 second smackdown
and the reason i think this club is
important is that it shows for all of
the bad that's been happening in uh in
the in western countries there there is
still an active resistance speaking up
and saying no
listen to this this is in relation to
the truckers protest the freedom convoy
the great honking and how trudeau and
kendall lied smearing these people
listen to this mr speaker i apologize
let me actually fix the audio canadians
i do get very defensive of canadians who
are outside today patriotic peace-loving
canadians who are called misogynists and
racists by the prime minister
so again i will ask the prime minister
who may i remind this house war black
face on more times than he can remember
apologize to the peace-loving patriotic
canadians who are outside right now just
asking to be heard will he speak to them
and then they all stand up and clap
so just to just to quickly summarize she
said you know he smeared these these
people these peaceful protesters a prime
minister and then you hear someone
actually say blackface prime minister
and then she says a prime minister who's
worn blackface more times than he can
remember
has the nerve to smear and insult these
working-class people so when we hear
these stories about how really bad china
is and and how it got to that point we
can see similar things happening here
we're actively resisting up in canada
they've got people obviously with the
freedom convoy the great honking people
are actively resisting in the u.s we're
getting stories now that maybe in the
u.s there's going to be some great
honking protests some trucker stuff so
i'm i'm fairly optimistic to be honest i
think i think we're going to resist all
this yeah i'm glad to see you optimistic
we have no place to go well also you're
running for office so i mean there we go
i mean even more optimistic well i hope
so i'm glad i'm glad i can make some
difference i feel it's my calling to do
this when i feel my country is becoming
like a china it's like a hell no how
about my three adult children how about
my grandchildren how about all the
freedom lovers
let me ask you though are there in china
are there people who are from america
going over there and being like we we've
got to make sure china stays like china
because it's becoming too much like
america with freedom yeah our businesses
[Laughter]
actually i have seen i haven't seen that
like the u.s council office staff and
families wanting to leave china now
because they cannot stand the zero kovi
policy but i mean are there americans
who defected to china who love communism
and want to live under that speaking in
the media being like america's terrible
and china's so good i don't remember any
that's why i think we need to volunteer
so they come in as professors from this
country and social justice warriors
please will you go to china you're gonna
love it send them over there yeah i will
pay for it i know you will
you do see though if you turn on um
the chinese state media so cgtv they
used to call it cctv9 but they changed
it to tv you will see westerners on
there american and british professors in
some cases who are going on that are
delivering you know these essential cct
uh ccp talking points on these things
talking about oh it's so great that
china has the olympics yeah
it's a wonderful yeah they're all being
they're making money you know and you
track it down and they had some like you
know maybe adjunct assistant faculty
position somewhere at some college that
nobody's ever heard of yet when they go
to china they're they're featured as
this great american scholar and here
they are and they are paid to push the
company line and we see this again and
again and again this is why there is an
actual elite merger going on i mean it
isn't even just you know there was that
harvard professor who was um charles
lieber who was finally convicted he
hasn't been sentenced yet but you're
seeing some of the stuff with mit the
scientists at gsk who just got arrested
in philadelphia area who are digging
into of course monoclonal antibodies so
this has been going on more and more and
more and yeah there are people who doing
it but i don't necessarily know if
they're doing it because they believe it
or they're just being paid well remember
the confucius institute
how naive we were allowed a chinese
government-funded organization called
confucius institute going to our
colleges set up schools in in middle
school high school to teach children our
children about china and glorify china
and
until they wake up it's like 15 years
later they have infiltrated china can
and like united states canada australia
and now you know what happened in
australia and you got hong kong
protesters right to support hong kong
student movement you got pro-beijing
people and they were fighting you in eu
and they're fighting in australia two
sides are equal it's like
wow communists are in the western
democracy countries everywhere yeah i
should i should just uh point out with
people like lebron james and mark cuban
and even i think elon musk has made some
positive statements about china as well
maybe they're not just in china
you know
going on chinese shows and being like
man you know china's so great and when i
see china becoming more like america i
said we have to stop this we need to
make you know but you have lebron james
you have the nba you have american
companies so it's probably worse so elon
and i think i talked about this before
last time i was on the show he's got his
twitter and on his twitter he'll be very
you know he almost like libertarian
sounding sometimes right on his twitter
account but elon's also got a wechat
account and wechat and he's got a weibo
account so these are this is chinese
social media and he'll go on there and
he's congratulating the ccp on their 100
year anniversary he's congratulating the
chinese government he's opening his new
tesla
showroom where in xinjiang in the actual
province where the weakers are all being
locked up so you know just something to
show that you know he's clearly got a
different message depending which
audience he's talking to
so so so what ends up happening here in
the united states uh are we are we gonna
see uh active resistance when when we
look over at quebec with the trucker
protests with the freedom convoy they're
pulling back the vax tax they're worried
about social cohesion but uh there are
some countries in europe that are
doubling down like you know austria's
and they've made the vaccine compulsory
i'm wondering
you know what happens here in the united
states because it's
i just don't see at this point how you
could possibly unite the left and the
right the barrier is solidified they
believe completely different things they
they will not listen to a word you say
it is it is just
two sides with no with no middle ground
i can i can united that needs the people
of new hampshire and the country because
i
um i'm the like inconvenient minority
who knows the strange exception of the
united states but also knows the
division of society that
caused by government and the media
colluding together to divide people yeah
but yeah i agree but i mean look they
say the the the funny point that was
brought up to us in a super chat was
that the left claims black people can't
be racist but candace owens is racist
i just feel like there is no
compromising and will be go away it was
perfectly fine yeah i know roseanne barr
gets fired from her show for making an
off-color joke whoopi goldberg outright
makes
crazy statements with the holocaust and
they're like well you know yes all we
have to do is speak to people who are
confused independent in the middle
that this kind of dividing is very
dangerous to our country and
our children because it's a typical
communist tactic like by mao he separate
people into oppressor versus suppressed
sounds familiar today
and the five black classes under
oppressor and five red classes under
oppressed then going through struggle
sessions and the gay people hate each
other and they control all the media
remember xinhua news agency was a
private media company when the ccp
funded 1920s
later they become the largest propaganda
machine in the world so i don't buy into
like oh i want to speak to egg they're
just private company i uh sure 100
private no government pressure no
government investment and no pcs like no
look at the shanghai news
so we have to kind of i want to trade
people with respect i know both sides
sometimes i think we need to tone down a
little bit to say i respect your
opinions even though i don't agree with
you but i'm waiting to listen to you
have conversation with you well it's
interesting because even these large
social media companies in the
organizations we refer to as big tech
many of them have investment from
inquitel which is actually united states
government run venture capital firm what
i would like to ask you lilly is
have you had any success at reaching
americans who identified as communists
or socialists as opposed to the people
in the center i gave you example i have
been going to colleges for past four
years to speak to students when i went
to west virginia right here right the
university
one bernie sanders supporter come to
listen to my story my talk he stayed for
a long time two weeks later
he went back to turning point usa
organizer and hostess to say please tell
lily
she changed my mind amazing wow and now
he joined the turning point usa wow
government sucks so they realized
i didn't ask her to say that yeah you
know
i don't i don't think the republican
party is the answer i think it's got to
be the people getting out voting in the
primaries voting locally
i say it like whatever it is if you
don't know what it is i remember seeing
you know in chicago's like vote for comp
troller and i'm like i don't know what
that is and but you've got to know what
it is you've got to vote for these
people because what happens is even your
school board ends up getting taken over
by you know marxists communists far
leftists
and they've
we've seen this in west virginia people
from the dc area that are ultra woke far
left
move out there specifically to get
elected to school boards so they can
start indoctrinating kids in
conservative areas in moderate areas in
apolitical areas that's what they want
to do they want to spread that message
so you've got to pay attention to who
these people are you're going to know
who you're voting for you got to vote
local you got to vote for your state rep
your state senator you got to vote in
the primaries because you're you're
running in the primary and if people
want someone like you to win they got to
go out in the primaries to vote yes
otherwise you get neocon establishment
republicans yes and you cannot be
afraid you cannot be afraid to call
white supremacists racist you have to
reject that those people who call you
there they just don't know the history
if they're young or if they do do that
it's marxist communist tactic don't be
afraid of them connie we have to
counter-strike to say you are marxist
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time